President Trump is reportedly
considering new sanctions against North
Korea North Korean state media released
new pictures overnight showing dictator
kim jong on watching military drills
running trump again hinted he may
confront the North without China's help
I said the way you're gonna make a good
trade deal is to help us with North
Korea otherwise we're just gonna go it
alone
that'll be all right too but going it
alone means going it with lots of other
nations Kim jong-il made a rare public
appearance overnight at the unveiling of
a massive new presidential complex in
the heart of the capital North Korea's
premier called the development more
powerful than hundreds of nuclear bombs
thence races in Pyongyang he witnessed a
high-profile spectacle then good morning
good mornings who are North Korean
guides told them we should meet them at
five o'clock in the morning they told us
we could not bring our cell phones and
they would not tell us where we were
going but by the time we eventually got
there the message they were trying to
send was pretty clear on the ride
through Pyongyang this morning we saw
North Koreans preparing for the upcoming
military parade we then saw large crowds
of people on either side of our bus they
brought us here to this street in
Pyongyang where thousands of North
Koreans have just flooded the streets
for what appears to be some sort of
elaborately staged media event and
security is quite tight security was
tight because North Korean president Kim
jong-eun showed up the sea of people
made it feel like the entire city was
there they at least appeared to be
loving the spectacle as their leader cut
the ribbon on what they called the
street of the Rising Sun it's an
economic show of force in the capital
that masks the extreme poverty still
pervasive in North Korea last October
our cameras captured the unfinished
buildings here it's now a massive
addition to Pyongyang with more than a
dozen modern high-rises some up to 70
stories tall constructed north korea
says in less than a year the quality of
that construction and the demand for the
units is unknown kim jeong-hoon did not
speak at this event but he didn't have
to he let these buildings do the talking
and his message to America is your
sanctions don't work we will keep
building our buildings and our missiles
new satellite image
examined by a North Korea watchdog group
suggest the country is preparing to
conduct a sixth nuclear test which could
be timed to coincide with this week in
celebration of North Korean founder Kim
ill soon president Trump has sent a navy
strike group steaming toward the Korean
Peninsula and has warned that all
options including a military one are on
the table now president Trump and
President Xi Jingping of China have had
at least one phone call about what other
options may exist in terms of dealing
with North Korea China is still North
Korea's main benefactor but appears to
be losing its patience
Noora meant racy there in north korea
interesting to see that in the course it
is one of the biggest concerns certainly
for the outgoing administration the
Obama administration and something that
the Trump team is worried about
everybody wonders how close are they
everyone will be watching Pyongyang this
weekend to see what happens and I'm soon
will they get the kind of missiles that
can deliver them to our coast